remember when the fearmongers on the
left warned us that President Trump
would isolate us from the world that
would have no friends well instead what
we've witnessed is growing alliances
with leaders such as French president
and Manuel macron and he's the guest of
honor at the president's first state
dinner tomorrow night let's discuss this
and other presidential issues with White
House deputy press secretary
Hogan Gidley staying up late with
delighted he's with us in studio I don't
know I just want everyone to see that
Hogan has an actual journal I mean I
love that you have an actual book not
like it's a laptop you're writing down
like a real old-school someone who's
preparing I just love that I miss John
take take note I gotta hope I hope you
take a token taking notes on the angle
tell me tell me about this Makran
relationship I love it because they were
all trashing Trump because he was gonna
offend the world now the world wants to
come here and meet him they thought the
Barack Obama apology tour was the way to
go about getting friends and allies and
it turns out it's the exact opposite
were feared again we're respected again
he's growing these relationships I mean
France has been well that's forever as
you know one of the actual first trade
deals we ever did quite frankly was
after we signed the declaration of
independence it was with France but he
is only gone to make this bigger and
better they are close friends they talk
all of the time the relationship
couldn't be better
this is the Huffington Post headline in
November Hogan you're gonna love this
let's look at it it only took Trump one
year to trash America's global
reputation and LA Times May 8 2017
France's election proves that America is
now example of what not to do but no one
ever calls these people on this stuff we
have this ongoing yeah we that's is that
yeah okay so that's that max boot who
wrote that yeah okay yeah never Trump er
of course former Republican of course a
liberal of course another self-loathing
Republic exactly well they're not
revoked they're never really worried so
it's not so but the the so-called
experts were wrong before the election
and now here they are again and they
just keep there they keep having their
gigs on TV their columns in the New York
Times The Washington Post but this
relationship with Makran getting back to
us it said he's an interesting cat for
Trump to be real with I mean he's kind
of putting his this
signal up for the move in France to put
expedited process on removal deportation
of immigrants in France he's not on
board with that so he's not a populist
like Trump is right he's more of the
globalist and more of them you know kind
of a moderate globalist in Europe so how
did the two how did the two have this
personal relationship well curious there
are some similarities and you heard
McCrone actually make the comment that
he was he used the phrase make him make
france great again just the other day on
one of the news networks think it was
actually Fox or the flood with a flood
of migrants from Germany well the point
is there were both former businessman
but both no one thought they could win
this election they come in and when
they're trying to do things differently
it is interesting because they don't
agree like on the Paris climate deal
they obviously don't agree on the Iran
deal the president's adamantly opposed
to that it wants that European trade
deal to which Trump doesn't want exactly
so there are some major differences here
but they just have a really good
relationship they're close personal
friends the president said today on the
way to marine one he said we're close
personal friend he's a good friend of
mine so they just had this great
relationship but Makran wants the
president the United States to stay in
Syria longer right until Isis is crushed
president's instinct and what he
campaigned on Hogan is that America is
not going to stay bogged down in these
places where we have no real political
solution a military solution excuse me
so will that relationship have an effect
on the president's ultimate decision to
stay in Syria everything we know about
france's relationship with you know and
sending sending technology and so forth
to russia and and even its relationship
with iran the Iran deal that's what
folks are worried about here well yeah
but I also think a lot of people were
worried about when Trump took over as
president at this town Washington DC
which shaped Donald Trump the exact
opposite has happened Donald Trump has
shaped this town
I think these relationships are similar
everyone says what's Trump going to do
is he can a kowtow to foreign leaders he
does not he's the best negotiator we
have he comes to the table and tells you
what he wants of course he wants to
bring troops home but he wants Isis to
be crushed and he wants to create an
environment there too which Isis cannot
ever rear its ugly head again and and
remember the last administration created
Isis this president wants to end it now
he shouldn't have signed the Omnibus
that was his instinct
it was right on that that omnibus was
not Trump's negotiating that was Paul
Ryan etc Hogan thank you for being here